high court erst mal ein großes
dankeschön dass die letzten videos von
euch alle so gefeiert wurden und heute
habe ich auch wieder was lustiges für
euch am start und zwar will ich mit euch
zusammen die ersten videos von youtube
anschauen und sie dann so ein bisschen
nach machen die ersten videos sind oft
nicht das worauf man als youtuber
unbedingt am stolzesten ist aber das
macht es ja so lustig ja deshalb würde
ich sagen beginnen wir einfach mal und
wie das so ist wenn ich irgendwie
youtuber verarsche das natürlich auch
luca nicht fehlen und ich hab schon mal
einen kleinen ausschnitt von diesem
video in der vario folge gezeigt dass
das erste video das auf seinem kanal
noch verfügbar ist und zwar minecraft
diamanten den unter fünf minuten
hey leute in diesem video zeige ich euch
einfach mal wir in einer
zufallsgenerierte welt in minecraft eure
ersten diamanten innerhalb von nur fünf
minuten findet okay leute das machen
jetzt nach um dieses video nachzumachen
muss ich eigentlich nur eine sache tun
und zwar mir die nase zu halten es war
was so lustig wie ihr damals geredet hat
deshalb muss ich das einfach nachmachen
ok dann drei zwei eins
hey leute diese video zeige ich euch
einfach bei mir zufalls geräte minecraft
oder ersten 45 minuten film mit dafür
stelle ich mir mal eben eine neue welt
wieder gesehen habt habe ich kein geld
einfach aus dem grund dass ich mir nicht
vorwerfen er habe vor hingeguckt von
ihrem update leute so macht ihr das
erste video von lugano
ich werde das heute folgendermaßen
machen es werden die ersten videos von
zwei mädels und zwei jungs geschaut
übrigens nicht wundern dass ich dir
immer spiegel und den ton ändert das
mache ich einfach nur damit die nicht
automatisch gestreikt werden falls
irgendjemand von den nachgemachten das
sieht würde ich euch das video nicht zu
streiken das ist ja alles nur fun und
spaß hier und da will ich sagen machen
wir weiter mit nummer zwei babys beauty
palace persönliche vorstellung heißt das
video
ich bin euch nochmal ein waren die
videos jeweils erschienen sind auf den
jeweiligen kanälen
ich habe mir gedacht jetzt wo ich meinen
ersten eigenen youtube kanal aus metall
mache ich als allererstes mal ein
vorstellungsvideo meine hobbys sind
beziehungsweise waren reiten gehen und
zum tanzen heute der mit abstand
lustigste teil ist er mit den hobbys
deshalb werde ich direkt zu dem hobby
teilt springen und am anfang nur noch
die begrüßung mitmachen hallo meine
lieben meine hobbys sind beziehungsweise
waren leichen gehen oder zum bepflanzen
ich habe auch selber kinder unterricht
gegeben
das jetzt leider die aufgaben gleich mit
studium weggezogen ok bei ihr fand ich
das aber bedeutet wie zieht man so schön
aus ist hier homeboy ja krank von
gefüllt bei baby fand ich es einfach
mega lustig sowie naja man würde heute
fast sagen wir ändern das war was sie am
anfang gesagt hat weil welche youtuber
erzählt heutzutage so in so einer
vorstellung von seinen hobbys so bei
youtube geht's heute einfach nur noch so
möglichst unterhaltsam sein und dabei
leider auch ein bisschen weniger von
sich selbst erzählen also bevor das
ganze hier zu dieb wird machen wir
weiter mit der nächsten person
es ist noch mal ein mädchen und zwar
katja ich bin einfach keine beziehung
so also die wahrheit auch damals schon
sowie die heute ist dann würde ich sagen
machen wir auch dieses video einfach mal
nach weil es so schön ist und 321 was
kaufen laden du musst mir doch nichts
kauft schnell war ich sprachlich
mitbringst ich wäre einfach keine
beziehung ich will einfach keine
beziehung mit dir lass mich einfach in
ruhe und mich doch ein verkehrt ich habe
das hier machen lassen darf wenn das
video feiert dann lassen liegt da also
bisher hat man so ein kleines muster
erkannt einig wo katja fast ein bisschen
raus gefallen ist die ersten videos sind
immer relativ simpel gehalten und nicht
so stark bearbeitet und ich ziehe mir
jetzt noch mal ein letztes erstes video
rein und zwar das von julien
[Musik]
dass hier wohl meine leichteste übung
das machen wir nach in 321 okay doch ich
hoffe euch hat das video gefallen falls
es das getan hat las gerne mal ein like
da ich habe heute übrigens ein neues
instagram foto gepostet den link dazu
packt ihr euch mal die beschreibung da
könnt ihr auch gerne folgen denn die
lust haben noch ein weiteres video von
mir zu sehen dann könnt ihr das hier tun
oder mich hier unten abonnieren dann
macht's mal gut sollte